on va répondre à toutes vos questions
autour de l'anus grâce au docteur Axel =
bonjour bonjour vous êtes hépato
gastro-entérologue et proctologue à
l'hôpital des diaconesses à Paris des
inondations record désincendies
spectaculaires ces derniers mois une
situation qui pourrait encore se
dégrader cette année et l'an prochain
l'Organisation météorologique mondiale
redoute le retour du phénomène El ninho
et même d'un super el ninio comme en
2016 ou sur ces images une falaise
s'était effondrée en Californie un mix
entre un camion un tram un train c'est
un camion à pantographe ça y est ça
vient d'être annoncé ça arrive en France
en 2025 en Alsace comment ça fonctionne
vous appuyez sur un petit bouton dans
votre camion soit électrique soit
hybride et au dessus de votre camion et
un système qui se déploie comme les
trains je vous assure j'ai cru que
c'était le graphique c'est-à-dire que le
phéritage en France je sais pas pourquoi
il est au point mort et il y a quelqu'un
un petit homme gris qui rajouter des
quatre nerfs sur les autoroutes et qu'on
faisait rouler lesquels on est même vous
vous riez mais je vous assure ce pays
est complètement fou en fait ce sont des
complètement
vous imaginez l'investissement que c'est
de mettre des caténaires sur l'autoroute
pour qu'on faire rouler des camions
électriques c'est une aberration et je
trouve que si parfait pour notre période
actuelle on est en période de transition
et ça permet au camion hybride ou
électrique de se recharger et ensuite de
se déplacer ailleurs et d'aller à leur
point de livraison vous aussi vous avez
des problèmes de chaleur et de manque
d'eau alors effectivement la chaleur
commence à monter fort heureusement ici
en France les nuits sont encore fraîches
donc du coup on arrive à un petit peu
reposer nos plantes et aux problèmes
d'eau ça fait des années déjà qu'on y
réfléchit heureusement 13 est quand même
très économe en eau parce que là on est
pas dans le sol c'est-à-dire que vous
êtes vous êtes
racontez-nous comment vous
allez on va pas y arriver va au milieu
du mannequin
moi je fais toutes les manifs à
Marseille
on va commencer par le commencement moi
je suis pas une députée
dans toute sa vie ok ok
qu'est-ce que je suis content d'être là
ah mais c'est top ça
n'aillent plus manifester pourquoi tu te
sens visé je parle pas de la police je
parle de toi je parle des gens comme toi
d'accorder les policiers je te dis tout
de suite
sur le plateau vous prenez vous vous
portez pas comme des Black Blocs s'il
vous plaît
je pense qu'à ce stade il faut lancer
une grenade de désencerclement sur le
plateau
c'est un cri du cœur celui de supporters
parisien en colère après une nouvelle
saison compliquée c'est un cumul de
choses qui font que les gens n'en
peuvent plus n'en peux plus du sportif
qui est inexistant on a des joueurs qui
se battent pas pour pour nos couleurs
qui respectent pas le club
belle ambiance en cause le choix du
septuple Ballon d'Or Lionel Messi de
partir en tournée promotionnel en Arabie
Saoudite quelques jours après une
nouvelle défaite en championnat et sans
l'accord du club
l'Argentin a été sanctionné Neymar aussi
en a pris pour son grade plus grave
encore certains supporters se sont
permis de manifester leur mécontentement
devant le domicile de la star
brésilienne
[Applaudissements]
Manu et le voisin de Neymar et hier soir
on a vu ces images de supporters
parisiens qui sont venus manifester
devant chez Neymar c'était pas trop le
bazar dans le quartier hier soir ça a
été alors moi j'ai pas entendu parce
qu'en fait il habite en contrebasse chez
moi donc en fait quand il fait des
énormes bringues quand je pars à 4h du
matin pour venir ici par exemple
j'entends
la playlist Neymar d'ailleurs je la
recommande elle est excellente enfin ici
mais le bruit monte comme ça le son
monte mais là non j'ai pas entendu ils
ont pas crier assez fort le Paris
Saint-Germain condamne avec la plus
grande fermeté les agissements
intolérables et insultant d'un petit
groupe d'individus qui ont eu lieu ce
mercredi quel que soit les différents
rien ne peut justifier de tels actes le
club apporte tout son soutien à ses
joueurs à son encadrement et à toutes
les personnes concernées par ces
comportements on te fins de citation
ok moi j'ai commandé la course
j'ai commandé la course en fait donc
voilà vous mettez pas vous vous mettez
pas mes affaires alors clairement le
gars alors donc
touche pas à mon sexe
quoi mon téléphone ça s'il te plaît
toujours plus de ventes en 2022 et
encore plus en 2023 selon un rapport
d'une association américaine la flotte
de jet privé a plus que doublé en 20 ans
ont des nombres plus de 23000 jets
privés dans le monde contre 9000 au
début des années 2000 avec la
possibilité désormais de transformer ses
avions de ligne en Palace volant comme
ce Boeing 737 aménagé pour 19 personnes
rubis tu peux pas
le monde tu prends très rapidement des
tours et comprendre que ça puisse
énerver aussi on t'a pas fait de
violence on t'a pris ton téléphone
démarre et allez on dirait on dirait la
meuf qui était venu à la famille
nombreuse
c'est insupportable Cyril et de ce défi
Paul tu feras 500000
donc ici c'est en quelques sortes la
pièce à vivre au salon quand vous avez
des rendez-vous d'affaires un peu plus
détendu et juste derrière c'est une
table vraiment grande un espace diné
hors du commun
et plus loin encore derrière vous avez
la cabine propriétaire avec un lit king
size quelque chose d'impossible à
trouver dans des avions plus petits
c'est un drôle de manège qui a mis en
place le gérant de l'attraction Mountain
Monster ah le système de freinage ne
fonctionne pas
c'est un public sur Tik Tok c'est vidéo
où il piège ses clients le faux problème
change ici un souci de ceinture mais la
réaction reste toujours la même
vous y étiez
en 1985 non je vous remercie je devais
avoir 27 ans à l'époque
ce qu'il faut savoir au sujet du roi
c'est qui les très fun
il a énormément d'énergie et il adore
s'amuser
il est adorable il peut être très
sérieux à propos de sujets qu'il estime
important mais il a aussi cette capacité
impressionnante à se tourner en ridicule
ce mensonge le plus improbable que vous
ayez jamais sorti
une bêtise avec un pote donc
de la côte
c'est lourd
[Rires]
comment on dit chez moi t'es pas une
femme c'était pas un homme donc on fait
tout